bonsoir Monsieur dutille c'est un
plaisir de vous accueillir sur notre
plateau ma question est très simple
comment vous allez comment allez-vous
monsieur dit-il ça va bien moins ta
santé pour notre ouvrage ça fait que
ça c'est jamais terminé mais c'est
parfait donc
vous êtes en affaires ça fait j'ai
commencé à travailler à 18 ans en 1961
ouais à Saint-Julien comme soudeur donc
ça fait plus de 60 ans ça fait
deux ans ok et vous êtes toujours
d'abord président du conseil de Can-Am
mais également PDG de la division
pont-canada donc vous êtes toujours dans
la gestion quotidienne des activités
d'une partie des activités de canon
comme il faut plutôt
directeur général des opérations de pont
on a trois usés au Canada un usés aux
États-Unis
et là vous vous lancez un appel en
faveur de d'une meilleure politique
d'achat local ce qu'on pourrait appeler
face au bail américain
un bail Canada expliquez-nous ce que
vous proposez prenons comme Can-Am on a
une usine aux États-Unis dans les portes
ok et tu as pas le choix aux États-Unis
c'était un boulon qui vient du Canada
dans un projet qui est financé par
Washington ça marche pas c'est
complètement défendu à 100%. et les
Américains peuvent venir ici tant qu'ils
veulent les Chinois peuvent venir ici
les Italiens les Espagnols faites moins
ta compétition avec la terre et puis
on n'a pas le temps d'aller aux
États-Unis puis on vendront pas de
ponche en Chine ou un ben d'accord non
pas en Espagne non plus pour n'avoir pas
aux Italiens non plus ça peut au moins
il devrait avoir un minimum de contenu
canadien québécois dans les projets
d'infrastructure mais il y en a un le
25% dont on parle puis Nova Bus encore
aujourd'hui on en parle dans le dossier
de novembre dans les projets de
l'infrastructure de pont il y a pas de
minimum ok le 25 % s'applique pas de
contenu canadien ça fait non non
en fait compte quand les projets
commencent à être assez gros de mettre
un deux trois cent millions ben il y a
les Chinois les Espagnols
que les Italiens qui viennent sur le
marché plutôt ok ça fait correct mais
avec notre main d'oeuvre
à Québec puis à Saint-Georges plutôt les
T4 là c'est c'est pas 20 pièces de
l'heure c'est une T4 dans l'autre
bénéfice marginaux c'était en haut de 80
4000 ça fait pour l'ensemble de nos
employés syndiqués donc c'est difficile
de faire concurrence à l'un de la Chine
au Mexique à toute à plusieurs pays du
monde qui viennent soumissionner sur les
appels d'offres ici oui et donc vous
vous pensez quoi vous vous croyez qu'on
devrait avoir un pourcentage de combien
si on met un pourcentage là de contenu
canadien dites-moi pourquoi que les
Américains sont à 100% autres que
d'autres faudra avoir un pourcentage de
30 40 50 quoi qu'on n'aurait pas 100%
je le demande pas là mais il faut qu'en
fait quand que nos gouvernements locaux
qui baptisent un projet d'infrastructure
et le bon prix pour qu'il y a cette
compétitions localement
pour donner le prix correct ça fait que
tu peux pas avoir un monopole sur
J'accepte ça 100% puis au Québec ce que
tout le monde oublie en fabrication de
charpente métallique
on est le plus gros fournisseur pour la
Nouvelle Angleterre que ce soit de
marché de New York de baston les Canada
les ADF les
procon on a 48
organisations qui vendent aux États-Unis
toute par nostario puis dans l'Ouest
canadien parce que vous avez aussi des
installations aux États-Unis pour être
capable d'avoir les contrats américains
dans les ponts dans les ports mais dans
le charpente il y a pas de il y a pas de
frontières mais si est-ce qu'il y a
assez de concurrence au Québec puis au
Canada pour avoir des contrats qui
seraient quasiment à 100% là si on a si
on va avec ce chiffre-là c'est au Canada
ça ça viendra pas avantager beaucoup
Can-Am il y a une chose qui est certaine
ça fait des contrats en haut de 20300
millions ça va être deux trois
compétiteurs sur cette maison parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une chose qu'on ne
faut pas oublier la bonne dingue puis la
chair Bandung de nos banquiers puis les
compagnies d'assurance et on s'est
ravissent au cours dernières années
beaucoup ok là Texas dans certains cas
un gros projet ça nous donne un avantage
je le reconnais mais tu as des EDF tu as
des chérubini
halifacs
donc ça prend quoi pour arriver à ça ce
que vous proposez
qui arrive avec
pourcentage puis qu'on ait des prix
corrects compétitifs et puis en
fin de compte peut-être que je compte
mal mais un projet donné par un
gouvernement provincial elle promet 20%
là il revient en taxe sur une forme ou
une autre les taxes sur les employés les
salaires les taxes après qu'on doit
payer nos taxes au Québec on paye un
autre 15% pour tout ce qu'on dépense
après ça il y a des taxes tout le long
tu sais le transport on paye des
surcharges de fuel
c'est quoi
c'est une fibre c'est 50% de taxes
on essaye on suit les lois
internationales on a des ententes avec
25% puis tout est
pas permission le nom de le pardon le
reste de temps monsieur dutyle sur la
fermeture vous êtes un fier beauceron
bien sûr on vous connaît bien mais sur
la fermeture de l'email qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de l'annonce de la
fermeture de l'usine de l'immel avagée
Vallée Jonction ben premièrement c'est
un de nos premiers clients Turcotte sur
mail dans les années 70 quand il faisait
des agrandissements les premières
poutrelle que j'ai vendu c'était à
Monsieur Turcotte
à l'e-mail cette valeur en partant le 8
900 emplois c'est un homme spécialement
d'embauche
la main d'oeuvre ne vient pas
nécessairement
d'agrannes parties d'aller jonquer on
l'a bien peut-être de Saint-Frédéric
je pose vous connaissez à Beauce un peu
on peut se promener
Saint-Georges puis tout seul ça peut
être la main devient des paroisses
environnantes comme nous à Saint-Georges
à 900 personnes pour Manach mais ça
vient de des petits villages alentours
ok monsieur dutille merci de votre
passage c'est un plaisir de vous
accueillir merci merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]